se han medido las presiones arteriales
de siete pacientes después de haberles
administrar un fármaco por tres meses
tuvieron incrementos en la presión
arterial de nos dan siete valores de
datos medidos en no sé alguna unidad de
presión arterial construye un intervalo
de confianza el 95% para el verdadero
incremento esperado en la presión
arterial para todos los pacientes en una
población aquí tenemos la distribución
de la población es razonable suponer que
es una distribución normal pues es un
proceso biológico así que si
administramos dicho fármaco a cualquier
persona esto va a resultar en un
incremento promedio en la presión
arterial un incremento promedio o quizás
un decremento y también vamos a
encontrar una desviación estándar aquí
una desviación estándar aquí tenemos una
distribución normal y es razonable
suponer que es una institución normal
pues es un proceso biológico va a ser la
suma de miles de millones de eventos
aleatorios y procesos que son la suma de
miles de millones de eventos aleatorios
tienden hacia una distribución normal
así que esta es la distribución de la
población
de la población y realmente no conocemos
nada de esta distribución tan solo la
muestra que tenemos aquí ahora lo que
podemos hacer es y eso es lo que se
aconseja cuando tienes una muestra
simplemente calcular todo lo que se
pueda a partir de esa muestra desde el
primer momento así que tenemos siete
valores de datos lo que podemos hacer es
sumarlos todos dividirlos entre siete
para obtener la media muestral la media
muestral aquí es entonces 2.34 y también
podemos calcular la desviación estándar
muestral encontramos el quad de la
distancia de cada uno de estos puntos
con respecto a la media los sumamos lo
dividimos entre menos uno porque es una
muestra
posteriormente tomamos la raíz cuadrada
para obtener la desviación estándar
muestral me adelanté para ahorrar tiempo
y obtuve que la desviación estándar
muestral es 1.04 y no sabemos nada de la
distribución de la población lo que
hemos hecho para empezar es estimar
hemos estimado esta característica con
la desviación estándar muestral así que
hemos estimado la verdadera desviación
estándar de la población con la
desviación estándar muestral
la desviación estándar muestral ahora en
este problema en este preciso problema
nos estamos metiendo en un problema
estamos estimando nuestra desviación
estándar con una n de tan sólo 7 por lo
que muy probablemente esta no va a ser
no va a ser una tan buena estimación
pues déjame escribirlo así directamente
n es pequeña en general esta es una mala
estimación 100 es menor que 30 arriba de
30 ya estamos en el nivel de las buenas
estimaciones por lo que el enfoque de
este vídeo es al considerar la
distribución muestral la cual vamos a
usar para generar nuestro intervalo en
lugar de suponer que la distribución
muestral es normal como hicimos en
vídeos anteriores
usando el teorema el límite central y
todo eso vamos a ajustar la distribución
muestral no vamos a asumir una
distribución normal pues esta es una
mala estimación vamos a asumir algo que
es conocido como distribución de una
distribución ts
y la mejor manera de pensar esto es que
fue hecha precisamente para dar las
mejores estimaciones de intervalos de
confianza y todo eso cuando de hecho
tenemos tamaños de muestra pequeños se
ve muy similar a la distribución normal
también cuenta con su media aquí tenemos
la que es también la media de la
distribución muestral sin embargo esta
distribución tiene con las gruesas tiene
colas gruesas la manera como la veo por
la cual tiene con las gruesas es cuando
supones una distribución estándar como
esta déjame ir un poco antes para
explicarlo normalmente lo que se hace es
encontramos una estimación de la
verdadera desviación estándar y decimos
la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral es igual a la
verdadera desviación estándar de la
población dividida entre la raíz de n en
este caso en es igual a 7 y luego nos
damos cuenta que nunca conoces la
desviación estándar o rara vez la puedes
conocer pero por general nunca la
conoces así que si no conocemos eso lo
mejor que podemos hacer es poner en su
lugar la desviación estándar de la
muestra pondremos aquí la desviación
estándar de la muestra y esto de aquí es
la razón esencial por la cual no decimos
simplemente que tenemos 95 por ciento de
probabilidad es la razón por la cual le
llamamos intervalo de confianza porque
estamos haciendo algunas suposiciones
esto de aquí va a ir cambiando de
muestra en muestra y en particular esta
va a ser muy mala estimación cuando
tenemos un tamaño de muestra pequeño un
tamaño menor a 30 así que cuando estamos
estimando la desviación estándar cuando
no la conocemos y le estamos estimando
con la desviación estándar de la muestra
el tamaño de muestra es pequeño y vas a
usar esto para estimar la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestral
podemos suponer entonces que la
distribución muestral es una
distribución normal asumimos que tiene
con las gruesas y tiene con las gruesas
porque esencialmente estás subestimando
la desviación estándar aquí subestimando
la desviación estándar en fin dicho esto
vamos a atacar el problema necesitamos
construir un intervalo del 95% alrededor
de esta media así que un intervalo de
95% si ésta fue una distribución normal
simplemente buscaríamos los valores en
la tabla z pero no lo es
esto es una distribución de distribución
te buscamos un intervalo de confianza el
95% es decir un intervalo alrededor de
la media que comprenda el 95% del área
para una distribución te vamos a
utilizar una tabla t y yo ya me adelante
y aquí tengo una tabla t y para lo que
nosotros necesitamos usaremos la fila de
las dos colas que tenemos aquí y la
mejor manera de ver esto es que tenemos
simetría alrededor de la media y es por
eso que le llaman de dos colas si fuera
de una sola cola tendríamos una polea
acumulativa
cierto umbral pero en este caso es de
dos colas es simétrica otra manera de
ver esto es que estamos excluyendo a
ambos lados queremos entonces el 95% en
el centro aquí tenemos la distribución
muestral de medias distribución muestral
para n igual a 7 y no voy a entrar en
detalles aquí pero cuando n es igual a 7
tenemos 6 lados de libertad o n 1 y la
manera confusión las tablas t es que vas
a buscar tus grados de libertad no vas a
buscar el valor de n vas a buscar n
menos uno que en este caso es 6 así que
si tú quieres abarcar el 95% aquí vas a
buscar en la tabla conseguidor de
libertad y tenemos que es 2.447
desviaciones estándar en ambas
direcciones y esta tabla te supone que
estás aproximando esa desviación
estándar usando la desviación estándar
de la muestra otra manera de ver esto es
que tienes que ir 2.447 de estas
desviaciones estándar aproximadas déjame
hacerlo por aquí entonces tienes que ir
2.447 esta distancia aquí es 2.447 por
esta aproximada por esta aproximada
desviación estándar la aproximada
desviación estándar y en ocasiones y
esto lo vas a ver en libros de
estadísticas
este número de aquí lo vas a ver escrito
así un sombrerito arriba de la
desviación estándar indicando que es una
aproximación usando la desviación
estándar de la muestra así que le
ponemos el sombrerito pues honestamente
esto es lo único que podemos calcular
así que esto es lo que tienes que ir en
cada dirección y conocemos este valor
conocemos la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral saquemos entonces
la calculada vamos a sacar la
calculadora
aquí tenemos la calculadora y sabemos
que la desviación estándar de la muestra
es 1.04 dividido entre la raíz cuadrada
de 7 lo cual es igual a punto 39
esto resulta punto 39 esto de aquí es
punto 39 esto es igual a
0.39 y si queremos encontrar la
distancia alrededor de esta media
poblacional que abarca el 95% de la
población de la distribución muestral
tenemos que multiplicar punto 39 por
2.400 47 hagamos eso esto por 2.447 nos
da igual a punto 96 así que esto es
igual a esta distancia de aquí esta
distancia de aquí es igual a 96 y esta
distancia de aquí también es igual a 96
así que si tomamos una muestra aleatoria
y eso fue lo que hicimos cuando tomamos
estas siete muestras cuando tomamos
estas siete muestras y tomamos su media
esa media puede verse como una muestra
aleatoria de la distribución muestral de
medias así que la probabilidad y esto lo
podemos ver podemos decir que hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad 95% de
probabilidad de hecho debemos de ofrecer
todo con la palabra confianza debido a
todas las estimaciones que hemos estado
haciendo
y no tenemos la certeza el 95 por ciento
de probabilidad tenemos 95 por ciento de
confianza que la media de la muestra
aleatoria que obtuvimos aquí que esté
2.34 por así decirlo s 2.34 lo tomamos
de manera aleatoria de esta distribución
que tenemos acá así que hay 95 por
ciento de probabilidad de que 2.34 se
encuentre
se encuentre
096 de la media verdadera de la
distribución muestra al que como
nosotros ya sabemos es lo mismo que la
media poblacional entonces de la media
poblacional o podemos reescribir nuestro
enunciado para establecer que hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad que la media
la media verdadera que es la misma que
la media y la distribución muestral se
encuentre
ah
096 de la media de la muestra que es
2.34 tenemos entonces que el límite
inferior es 234 2.34 menos 96 es el
límite inferior del intervalo de
confianza que es 1.38 y el límite
superior del intervalo de confianza que
es 2.34 más punto 96
este es 3.3 así que el intervalo de
confianza del 95% va de 1.38 a 3.3